sadness and anger at the vigil in the
murder favela one of the largest slums
of rio de janeiro
residents gathered on friday one day
after a police raid left 19 dead
they protested against the violence they
say they've been facing for decades
violence is a product of government
policies which have left the poor with
no jobs no schools no food on the table
if a young boy is holding a rifle now
that's because in 2010 when he was a
child he was given no opportunities
four hundred policemen surrounded the
moldova on thursday new video shows them
shooting down a man
the police say they were targeting
leaders of the red commando one of
brazil's largest drug gangs but met
resistance
the criminal leaders ordered their men
to resist arrest or face retaliation
16 suspects one policeman and two
innocent bystanders were killed spurring
public outrage
three of the four most lethal police
raids in the history of rio de janeiro
happened during the past
14 months
more than 70 people were killed
including those who died here in the
mojo duale mount favela
president
has long favored heavy-handed police
tactics
but human rights organizations and crime
experts say violence has proven to be
ineffective
all these deaths have not stopped
criminal gangs from growing stronger so
why insist on lethal operations instead
of concentrating on investigation and
intelligence gathering that's what will
prevent drug lords from getting armed
at the vigil on friday residents of the
favela prayed for peace and the future
of their children
monika yanakev al-jazeera rio de janeiro